[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT TAVIS: Thank you for
making it all the way over here.
I know you had to hoof
it over from Moscone.
So I appreciate you swinging by.
Today, I want to talk
about GKE On-Prem, which
is all part of-- the
new name is what?
Yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Anthos.
MATT TAVIS: Anthos, there we go.
All right, excellent, good.
The marketing is working.
So yeah, we're going
to talk about--
and we'll obviously
touch on Anthos a bit
as well, because you can't
talk about GKE On-Prem
without a little bit of Anthos.
So we'll touch on that a bit.
My name is Matt Tavis.
I'm a solutions architect.
What that means is I spend
most of my time either writing
things down about
how to use this stuff
or working with customers
and telling them
how to use this stuff.
So that's basically what I do.
And my focus specifically
is in the hybrid space.
So I've actually spent a fair
amount of time with the PM team
on the Anthos product suite,
talking to them about what
these products
can look like, how
they're going to roll out, how
people should play with them.
And so today, I'm going to
talk a bit about GKE On-Prem.
And then specifically,
I'll show you
that actually
functioning outside
of the cloud on an environment
setup on packet.com.
And then I'll do some
demos there a little bit.
And then I will turn it over to
Tobias Palmborg, who's actually
one of our customers,
who's already
used this for his business.
And he'll tell you
more about that.
So that's the plan
for this morning.
So just a quick recap,
I put this in here
for the people that are
reading on the recording.
Mostly you've seen this.
It's about GKE On-Prem,
but also even how
you can tie that into
more of a CI/CD pipeline.
Actually how config management
and Git can actually
be used as a way to even
control your clusters
and manage them as well.
So both those will be
covered in today's session.
So let's start with
why we actually
are even having this
conversation to begin with.
So GKE On-Prem is obviously
a on-prem version of GKE.
Who uses GKE today?
Excellent.
So we got a lot about Kubernetes
folks here that understand it.
GKE On-Prem premise the idea
of bringing that to a platform
other than Google.
And so that's because although
many people have mandated
public clouds-- they
want to use them, 73%--
but only 10% of workloads
have actually moved over.
So there's still almost 90% of
workloads in many enterprises
that are still in
on-prem environments.
So how do you
unlock the potential
of using the latest
cloud technologies
but in those on-prem
environments?
And so some have even moved
data back in some cases.
So we actually have
to contend with this.
There's always going to
be some element of hybrid
in most enterprises.
They're not just going to pick
everything up and just move it
all to the cloud tomorrow.
And even if they do, it's going
to be a transitional period.
So hybrid is really
pragmatic and persistent.
And so GKE On-Prem
is an opportunity
to bring some of
that cloud technology
into your existing
on-premises infrastructure.
Now, that shows up
in a lot of ways.
There's a lot of reasons why
you might have to even continue
on that path over time.
So for example,
let's say you really
want to unlock the cloud
for your development teams.
You want CI/CD.
You want full
automation pipelines.
You want to use the latest
tools and technologies.
You want to give them dev
environments that they
can turn up with a snap, right?
But it turns out when you
go to run it in production,
it's on a ship, or it's in a
store, or it's in a factory.
You actually have
this split model of,
I need to be able to
build locally in the cloud
and then I need to
push to someplace else.
So GKE On-Prem is giving
containers everywhere.
That's that model.
Another model that requires
hybrid and requires
this kind of mixed
environment is jurisdictional.
I'm writing code,
but fundamentally,
the actual execution,
or even the data
itself, has to live in
a specific location.
There's rules about
where it can reside.
And therefore, I need
the cloud technologies
close to my data, which has
to stay in a certain spot,
where maybe there isn't
a cloud data center.
So that's another common model.
And then the third
we've seen quite often
is even this
best-of-breed services.
I want to run some things
local against my data sets
through there.
But then I also want to tap
into, say, machine learning
or data warehousing technology.
So I want to bridge these
architectures, where
I have a local execution,
then I actually
tap into a data set in the
cloud or a certain function
in the cloud.
And so all of these are reasons
why you might actually end up
having a hybrid scenario and
why you might need something
like GKE On-Prem.
In swoops Anthos, once called
Cloud Services Platform,
now called Anthos.
And the idea here is it's a
collection of cloud services,
but it's also a collection
of marketplace components.
And we'll see some of that.
You can actually tie-in to
the existing GCP marketplace
both for in the cloud but also
in the on-prem environment.
As well as the control
plane, the idea
being that once you've
taken this leap into using
this hybrid model
that goes everywhere,
you can now run that--
The same way you'd
run it on GCP,
you run it on-prem
with the same tools
and technologies, the same back
end services and other clouds.
So that is the long
term goal here.
So we'll talk about how it
looks today a little bit more,
so the fundamentals
of that platform.
But really, the reason why
we think this makes sense
and what we've been hearing
from a lot of our customers
about why this is
something they want one,
it's this ability to
modernize in place.
I want to leverage the latest
in development technologies,
such as containers or Kubernetes
or even things like Istio
for service mesh
management, but I
want to do it where I have
my infrastructure today.
I want to learn how to
modernize what I have,
as opposed to having to move
everything to the cloud first.
| second reason why people
are liking this approach
fundamentally is the ability
to automate policy and security
at scale.
So some of these components
in this platform--
such as, say, Istio
for service mesh
for managing your access
between individual components
or elements in your
container architecture
or config management, which
allows you to automatically
apply configuration
to your clusters--
are about the ability
to manage that sprawl
that you see that
starts to occur
when you have microservices
and containers in lots
of different places.
How do I keep a consistent
policy on top of that?
How do we have a consistent
security profile and a security
stance and configuration
stance everywhere?
And that's another
goal of what the Anthos
platform is really focused on.
And the last is really
that consistent experience,
not really so much for your
users, but for your operators,
for your developers, and
for your administrators,
so they have a consistent set
of tools, a consistent approach
that they take everywhere.
So they're learning different
technologies, different tools
on each cloud or
platform they use.
They'll only need one, set one
tool chain across the board.
So they're writing code the same
way no matter where it runs.
They're running the same kinds
of scripts for automation
no matter where it's
actually functioning.
And then ultimately, you
have the same dashboard
of visibility of what's
happening everywhere,
no matter where that code is
running, no matter where it's
being developed or deployed.
So that's fundamentally the
goal of the overall platform.
And this is sort of
a little view into it
to give you a sense of all
the pieces that play in there.
And we're going to
talk more about--
The GKE On-Prem is in that
bottom right, you see.
That's where we've deployed
GKE to a specific cluster.
But there's more to it when
you look at the full platform.
In terms of things like
additional services,
you might tap into, say,
Stackdriver or Cloud Run,
which was talked
about this morning
in the keynote, binary
authorization for the ability
to sign and certify
container images
and code that you're deploying.
All of those things
are additional services
you might add on
to your deployment,
if you feel they're appropriate.
Those can run both as
sort of a split model,
a little bit in the
cloud, a little bit
in your on-prem environment.
And then there's this
Marketplace component
I mentioned.
You saw actually probably
in the first day's keynote
there was a moment
where they showed
just a dropdown selecting, say,
CloudBees and hitting a button
and go.
And that deploys
it to your cluster.
The idea is that the GCP
Marketplace that's there
is tied directly in, so you can
deploy even purchased software,
paid components directly to
your clusters, whether they
be on-prem or in the cloud.
And then below that, we have
that control plane layer
we're going to talk
a little bit about.
There's three big pieces in
there-- config management,
the connect layer, and then, of
course, the service mesh, which
is akin to Istio and sort of
a managed service mesh layer.
GKE On-Prem is that bottom
right box, right there.
And it's really about bringing
the cloud style automation
to an on-premises model.
So big elements of why
this makes a lot of sense
is instead of
patching, upgrading,
and troubleshooting your
cluster, you can simply rebuild
and deploy.
It's much more automated
in terms of control,
in terms of getting
that rolled out.
And you can
programmatically provision
and scale that infrastructure.
So because now you've got tied
into the GKE On-Prem interface,
which looks very much
like the kubectl--
there's a new thing
called gkectl--
and it will go ahead
and spin up new clusters
and actually upgraded versions
of your Kubernetes running
on top of it for you.
So it does the automation
of that provisioning
of infrastructure
as part of that.
And it also will upgrade
software via controllers,
not manually.
So now, you actually are
getting the deployment
of the latest versions
of Kubernetes,
the exact same versions
that are running on GKE
in your on-prem environment.
So there's no worries
about version mismatch
across your platform.
And so the comparisons, if
you look at it, GKE versus GKE
On-Prem, I think I'll
skip the GKE side,
because sounds
like a lot of folks
kind of know what's out there.
But big notes to
make are that GKE
has been in GA since
August of 2015,
so longstanding
consumption usage pattern.
It's a fully managed
Kubernetes control plane,
takes care of a lot of
those things for you.
Now, on the GKE
On-Prem side, you'll
see now you're getting turnkey,
production-grade conformant
Kubernetes with
best-practice configuration.
So what that means is just like
with GKE where we're giving you
Kubernetes versions
to choose from that
have been vetted and
verified, same thing
happens with GKE On-Prem.
You're using the same versions
of the open source Kubernetes
platform that runs
in both environments.
There's an easy
upgrade path that
has been validated and tested
releases of Kubernetes.
So you know you're picking
something that's already
been tested and verified.
And of course, you
will still have access
to all those container services
that you use in the cloud.
So you can still use
Container Registry.
You can still use Cloud
Build for automation,
Audit Logging, pieces
like that, as well as
Stackdriver and other services.
However, you can
also use your own.
So there's no reason
why you couldn't
set up your own private
Container Registry on-prem
and point to that
instead of GCR.
There's no reason
why you couldn't
have your own build pipelines
that you run locally
and then deploy through those
in your on-prem environment.
So you're not tied
to those services,
but they're available to you.
So you have
flexibility and choice.
I think choice is the word
we used a lot yesterday
to describe Anthos.
Choice is what it's really
about, giving you options.
And of course, you
have full integration
with various other
open source components,
like, say, Istio, also
managed through cloud service
mesh, which is part of
the Anthos umbrella;
Knative, which is then
also talked to you
about is Cloud Run.
So you're seeing this
parallel, where the open source
projects are also then
available as offerings
through the Anthos platform.
And then the Marketplace
solutions as well.
So in terms of consistency,
the GKE versus GKE On-Prem,
you see there's a lot
of similarities here.
Operating systems
On-Prem is Ubuntu
versus the
Container-Optimized OS.
There's some minor
tool differences.
The console is the same. kubectl
is the same, or "kube ctl"
depending on what way you
like to pronounce that.
glcoud swaps out for
gkectl, so "gke cuddle",
which allows you to
spin up a new cluster.
And that's how you
deploy user clusters
inside the environment.
Calico is consistent across.
You've got Stackdriver.
You've got EFK in GKE
On-Prem, but you can also
use Stackdriver Logging.
You can use whatever
logging tools you want.
For monitoring,
Prometheus and Grafana
are deployed automatically, but
you can add Stackdriver plugins
as well if you want that.
So you have the ability to
keep it separate and isolated
or to actually bridge it in
with the existing services
that GKE uses as well.
What it kind of looks like--
and this is what we call
the Kubeception model,
clusters within clusters--
when you were to
deploy GKE On-Prem,
fundamentally you
build out first
an administrative cluster.
That's that top box.
That admin cluster has
its virtual machines
that are the control plane,
and then actually, if you will,
"masters" in sort of
the air quoted sense.
They are actually
control plane nodes
for the user clusters,
that then have elements
that fall underneath that.
So there's an admin cluster
that creates other clusters is
the way to think about that.
So when you go ahead and run
gkectl to, say, spin up a user
cluster, it will talk
to that admin control
plane, which works directly
with in V1 the vCenter APIs.
So it works directly with
the VMware, vCenter APIs,
to automatically
provision new VMs,
as well as working directly
with, in this case, F5 BIG-IP,
to provision network
address space and register
addresses for external
access to the cluster.
We'll cover some
of the networking
components in a second.
But fundamentally, that is
a fully automated deployment
of a whole new cluster.
Those images are spin up.
They have Kubernetes
pre-installed in them.
They come online.
They join the cluster.
And you can actually control
the sizing of those VMs
when you deploy them.
So it's all baked
in a configuration
that you can run
once to do a dry run
and then go ahead and
then deploy automatically.
So then you can create
multiple user clusters.
So if today, you might be
using different clusters
for different teams
or different services.
You'd do the same thing On-Prem.
You spin up a user
cluster for team
x, a user cluster for team y.
And then they have
completely isolated clusters
that you can control
individually.
And then you can use
DHCP or static IP
controls to decide how you're
going to allocate addresses.
So you have a little
bit control there
from a networking perspective.
And networking is one area
where this is different.
And we'll cover that in
just a second, because we
have this diagram,
which I'm sure
everyone's going
to want a photo of.
Don't worry, it's going
to be in the video too.
But the idea here
is that networking
is one thing that's quite
different with GKE On-Prem.
So when you think about
GKE running on the cloud,
you also have-- it
has full control
to the network infrastructure
upon which it runs.
That means it's allowed
to set up load balancers,
and make sure the routing
between IP ranges is set up,
and the IP address rules
or the IP filtering rules,
firewall rules are all
configured automatically
for you.
When you look at this running
in your on-prem environment,
inside the cluster
things work great.
All the components inside the
cluster can see each other.
But then things coming
from the outside
have to access those
services inside.
So that's where there
is a subtle difference.
And that's why there's a--
In my example, in this
slide, it's using F5.
Longer term, there's a
goal to bring your own load
balancer that you might
choose as opposed to that.
So this will be a
model where what
happens is when you're
spinning up a cluster,
it creates the node IPs, pod
IPs, and service IP addresses,
are all automatically
created based
on the ranges you give it.
You allocate the 10 dot
range or whatever private IP
range you want.
And then it will also, as
part of that spin-up process,
allocate the ingress VIP, the
service VIP, and the control
plane VIPs in F5.
So now, all of those services
that you might deploy,
or all of the components
you might deploy,
are accessible from
outside the cluster.
So other components
in your network,
inside your on-prem data
center, can now see those.
You choose what you
expose, just like you
choose what you expose in
GKE, by exposing a service
and making it available.
Same concepts, you're still
exposing a load balancer,
but you're choosing a particular
IP range that's known by F5,
so it can actually
expose that out
to the rest of the data center.
We'll actually take a look
at that in just a second.
The other thing that comes of
this is because that's great,
now you've got Kubernetes
running in your data center,
but you probably still want
to see what's happening,
you still want to have
that kind of visibility.
And so there is a
component that is optional.
You choose to add it.
It's called GKE
Connect, is a hub.
It is essentially something
you deploy into that cluster.
And what it does is it registers
that cluster with the GCP
platform.
So now, that cluster
shows up in your console
just like any other
cluster you have running.
So now you can see, oh, here's
my GKE cluster in us-central1-a
and here's my GKE cluster
running in On-Prem,
right next to each
other, dive right in.
Now, the way that works
is it will actually
install an agent inside
the GKE On-Prem cluster.
And then that agent
will actually dial back
using a gRPC TLS connection.
So it's encrypted dial-back.
You actually embed
secrets in there.
So it's safe.
It's part of the
manifest that is given
to you during the registration.
What happens is it will
actually callback to GCP
and then announce, hey,
here's how I'm doing.
Here's my alerts.
Here's what's going
on with my services.
Here's the info on my nodes
and my pods and storage.
All that kind of stuff
is reported back up.
So you can see it right there
in the console if you want to.
It also gives you the ability
to feed deployment information
back down.
So from the console,
you can deploy things
directly into an On-Prem
cluster, another thing
that we're actually
going to take a look at.
In fact, let's take a
look at that right now.
So what we have here is this
the Packet environment I set up.
So in Packet, all I did was--
Obviously, this is
a demo, so I didn't
want to spend too much money.
So I just spun up
one big machine
that has a lot of availability.
So it's got you 64
gigs of RAM, some SSD
is on there, a
24-core processor.
So it's sizable, good enough
to let me run my environment.
What's on there, though, the
most important thing to start
is I've actually got
VMware running on there.
And so I've got an
environment there
setup, which actually manages
all the VMware infrastructure.
So you can see all the
virtual machines in here.
Just like that
picture before, you've
got you know admin workstation.
You've got the F5
service appliance.
You've got master nodes,
the admin master nodes.
You've got a
networkservicesvm that
handles sort of
NATting and routing
between that environment.
Now, this is a specific
configuration for this demo.
It doesn't have to
run exactly like that.
And then there's the user
cluster component sitting
there and a vCenter Appliance.
So that's what we have
sitting in there in terms
of that infrastructure.
So what that gives
me is the ability
to go over here and say, kubectl
get pods --all-namespaces.
So you can see here I now have
all these individual things
running automatically.
I've got the gke-connect-agent
already in there.
That's great.
I've got Istio, is already
pre-installed in there.
We use Istio for some Layer 7
routing inside of GKE On-Prem.
You can obviously have a full
Istio deployment as well with
all the components.
Alert managers,
calico is in there.
You see configuration
management.
We'll talk about
that in a little bit.
kube proxies, there's some
F5 load balancer mapping.
Prometheus is in there.
So you've got logging
built-in baked in the cluster.
Now, the other
thing that happens,
of course, as I mentioned,
is that you can actually
see this cluster
directly in the console.
I'll reconnect that guy,
and we'll come back to him
in a second.
So if I go back here
to Kubernetes Engine,
I can see in my clusters that
there's my user-cluster1,
and my location is sjc.
So that's not actually
a GKE [CHUCKLES] domain.
And so I can jump in
here, and you can actually
see-- even on the storage
information right here,
look, you can see this is
datastore1 kubevols, vmdk.
So it's mapping to the
actual storage that's
provided underneath the covers
as part of a VMware vCenter
setup.
So you've got the
storage in there.
And then, of course, you even
the nodes information in here.
So you have each of the nodes,
what's available, 4 CPUs.
Out of 8 gigs, only 2.6 is used.
And I can dive into
an individual node
and see the actual
detail of what's running.
Here's all the components
that are running,
here's the CPUs available.
I can even see my
conditions about,
is it fail, like
any checks on disk
pressure or insufficient memory,
things like that-- all visible
right there in the console.
I can also go ahead, and
if I'm really daring--
because well, hey,
why not, I'm here;
the internet seems to be
working, this is awesome;
let's do it--
I can also just deploy
stuff directly from here
into that cluster.
So let's just go
ahead and deploy
nginx, because that's
fairly straightforward.
And we'll call it
nginx-1, that makes sense.
And there's user-cluster1.
See, it's in the list.
There's user-cluster1,
which is the one
that I have running On-Prem.
And I can go ahead and
Deploy right there.
And then we watch, and
stare, and cross our fingers,
and tap the table,
and cross our toes.
And oh, first green check
mark, second green check mark.
And I'm going to go for
that it's going to happen,
it's going to happen.
Waiting for Pods,
Waiting for Pods.
All right.
So that is deployed.
So now, if I were a GKE, I
could be like, oh, that's sweet.
So here's nginx-1.
That's awesome.
I'm just going to tap in here
and go, cool, let's Expose it,
because that's what I
would do on GKE, right?
Just hit Expose.
There's only one
challenge there,
which is that if
you view this YAML,
you'll see that there
is no load balancer IP.
Because what's going
to happen in GKE
is it's just going
to figure it out,
and it's going to give you one.
It's going to fake it.
No problem.
It's all taken care of.
GKE On-Prem, you've got to
be a little more specific.
That's where the F5 comes in.
That's where you have to say,
oh, use this IP from my F5
I've preallocated.
So I can't do it
exactly like this.
But don't worry, I've
got it all figured out.
Well, that's not exactly true.
I don't think I have
it all figured out,
but I've got a couple of
things in my head going on.
So let's go over
here and pop into--
this is that machine.
And so I actually have--
I will do a cat
nginx-service.yaml.
So I've got a service.yaml.
So the subtle difference
here is that now I've
got a load balancer IP
at the bottom there.
I picked one.
So that's 10.0.10.252.
Now, you'll probably notice
that's not routable either.
But it turns out there is a
funny little box at network
services admin in my
lab environment that
does some mapping between
internal and external IPs,
keeps my life straight.
In a production setup, you'd
actually have a load balancer
out there on the
edge that's actually
doing the mapping from the
outside to the inside IP
ranges, and it'd be fine.
Or you'd have a public one
you could choose right here.
But I can do that as I
can do a kubectl apply.
This is when you find out if
I really know what I'm doing.
It's a big test.
So it just created that
service, which is great.
And that service is on
this port right there.
So there you go.
Now, that's the public IP range
from the Packet environment.
That's being NATted
directly into the internal.
So there you go,
I've deployed nginx.
I've got a load balancer
that's picking up that traffic
and then routing it to
the internal workload.
I know you're stunned.
Don't fall out of your chairs.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHUCKLES]
Let's go back to
the presentation.
[LAUGHS] But of course,
the challenge here
is managing multicloud
hybrid environments
is super difficult,
because you've
got all sorts of central
IT and governments
rules people want to apply.
They want to make sure
it's consistent everywhere.
And this is just
creating sprawl, right?
Now, a single person, a
single node or cluster
has multiple
containers and layers
of layers of containers
and microservices.
It adds a lot of complexity.
So what they really
want in central
IT is this change control.
They want accountability.
They want a consistent
environment configurations.
They want to ensure consistency
with a single source of truth.
And so they want to be able
to remediate problems quickly
should something happen, even
across multiple environments
around the world.
So by adding this flexibility,
we're also adding complexity.
So how are we going
to solve that?
That's the real question.
So that's where Anthos
Config Management comes in.
Anthos Config
Management, you probably
saw this in the keynote.
I don't know if anyone
was paying attention.
There was at one
point the keynote
where they said git push on
one of the console screens.
Anyone catch that?
Anyone see the git push?
Yeah.
So that git push is this.
It's config management.
It's basically saying,
look, let's just use
Git as a single source of truth,
and let's make the clusters all
watch a repository and then
grab the configuration they
need for their setup.
So the idea here is you
can sync your configs
across all your clusters,
both on-prem and in the cloud.
And this enables
continuous configuration
of enforcement policy.
So you can say, for these
namespaces, for these clusters,
these are the YAML
files you have to apply.
It's in a repo.
It automatically happens.
And so if things change, it'll
go back and look at that repo
and be like, oh,
something changed.
I got to update the cluster.
If you try and make
changes to the cluster that
disagree with the
repo, it will get them
back to what the repo says.
So it actually will make sure
that environment stays in sync.
And we'll see that
in just a minute.
I have more demos.
Yes, I know.
Get comfortable in those chairs.
Don't fall off.
And this gives you auditability
through policy-as-code.
So now, you can also apply your
own checks, your own controls,
your own pipelines on
top of that repo that
allow you to make sure the
right people are doing it,
they're going through the
right checks and policies.
And there's even
a tool associated
with this that will vet your
configuration before you deploy
it, so it makes sure
it actually will work,
so there's components in there.
And so the idea here, though,
is it's really adopting
that config-as-code model.
It allows an Anthos
admin, somebody
who has accesses to
this policy repository,
to make sure they set up
the environment consistently
across the board.
And so this is
kind of an example.
As part of the docs this rolls
out, you'll see this example.
This is a policy repo.
And you can see
there's foo-corp being
sort of a top-level
namespace with online
being a namespace,
shipping-app-backend
being a namespace.
Now, the online is more
virtual, because there's really
nothing inside of it.
But as you get down
to, say, shipping-dev,
you see there's a
job-creator-rolebinding.yaml,
job-creator-role.yaml,
namespace.yaml, quota.yaml.
You can have a whole bunch
of YAML files in here.
And basically, anything you can
do to a cluster with a kubectl
apply yaml type command is
something you could mock up
as config as well.
So you can actually
do rolebindings,
you can do
deployments, you can do
service deployments, workloads,
whatever makes sense.
And so the idea here
is that you can then
use your classic
configuration formats,
YAML files, and then go
ahead and put those into Git
as a repo.
And then it plugs it easily
into your CI/CD pipeline
for making sure that it's
valid and correct as you go.
So the way this kind of works
is you might have-- in your GKE
platform, you're going to have
the config management operator.
So this is implemented
as a Kubernetes operator,
which basically is then keeping
track of a Git-compliant repo.
Your repo could be on-prem.
And your GKE On-Prem has
the operator installed.
It's syncing against that repo,
just like the GKE is as well.
So if your repo is
accessible to the GKE,
then you can use one repo.
You could also use, say,
GitHub or a private Git
repo if you want
deployed in the cloud
and then use that as
your point as well.
Also, you can use Google
Source Repositories.
So let's take a look at that.
Let's jump over to the demo.
So that was exciting.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm actually going to
install config management.
So what I want to do is show
you what that looks like.
It's a pretty simple script.
All it does here is it's
doing a kubectl apply.
This is basically applying the
latest version of this release.
The old name was
[? nomos. ?] It's
not called config management.
It installs a git credentials.
So I'm using SSH credentials.
I've actually installed
them in the cluster,
so that it can
find those quickly,
so it can access the repo.
And then I just apply a
config-management.yaml.
And if we cat that, you'll see
that's fairly straightforward.
It's pointing to here's
my user cluster, what
I want to call it.
Here's the endpoint that
I want you to go to,
the SSH endpoint for
the actual repo itself.
Sync with master,
always use master.
And then I'm going
to use SSH for that.
So the way I'm going
to do this, I'm
going to do
install-configmanagement.
And don't worry, there'll
be an error, but that's OK.
I know about that error.
I've already
installed the creds.
They were already in there.
So installing them again
doesn't work, obviously.
So that's now going.
So what's going to happen is
it's going to start immediately
looking at that repo.
So if go in here and I
go back to Clusters--
I'm sorry, go to
Workloads, there
will be a couple of new
things in here already.
And that's the
config management.
You can see there's
the git-importer.
There's a syncer.
There's monitor.
These are part of that
config management system.
And these will start and
deploying themselves.
Once they're in
there, setup working,
they're going to start
talking to that repo
and then looking for
what needs to happen.
Now, while that's going
on, because that's not
instantaneous, as
you can imagine,
as much as I'd
like it to be, I'll
show you quickly kind of
what that repo looks like,
so you get a sense of
what's going on in there.
There's a couple of
areas in this repo that
are worth noting.
There's the
clusterregistry area.
And here, you can actually
set up your clusters.
So the reason why
you might do this
is because you might have
different environments that
have different sets of rules.
And I'll show you how that
plays out in the config.
But you can register
all your clusters here.
And then as you add
them, you say, oh, here's
the parameters I want you
to use for this cluster.
That flows down into your
namespace's definition
to pick the right
versions of elements.
As an example, if we go
to namespaces and we go
into the k8s-manifest,
you'll see in here--
if I can find it--
this is all the different
things that are in here.
So here's the GKE On-Prem
on Packet you see.
And so what I'm doing is I'm
doing a cluster-selector,
saying, if it's
a packet cluster,
then I want you to do
something different.
And what's different here--
it's really not much different--
down here, I added an
environment platform variable
that I want to show up on
that cluster specifically.
It changes how the code
operates in that cluster.
We'll see how that
happens in a second.
I also have, if I go down
here, also on Packet,
I have the LoadBalancer setup.
So you'll see here, I actually
added the loadBalancerIP,
like we talked about earlier.
I have to have a
loadBalancerIP in GKE On-Prem,
whereas I don't
have that on GKE.
So for on GKE, it
looks like this.
There's no loadBalancerIP.
So let's take a look and make
sure that's actually happening.
Let's refresh here.
OK, yeah, look, wow.
It actually worked.
Huh?
[CHUCKLES] Sorry.
That wasn't shock.
I apologize.
[LAUGHTER]
That was enthusiasm,
totally different thing.
No, it works fine,
it works fine, yeah.
No, it's great.
But it's all setup,
so all green already.
And what thing you'll
notice is right here
frontend-external is set to
load balancer 10.0.10.251:80.
And so if I go to that
URL, which is not here,
that's not 29 but
actually 28, there you go.
So we've got the hipster--
or it was called
Hipster, now called
Online Boutique, same thing you
saw in the keynote, same app.
It's actually the
same code base.
I just pulled it down
for this environment,
so you could see the same
And you can see this
On-Premises here.
That's because that's
actually tied to where
the environment is running.
That's that variable
I was passing in--
On-Prem versus GKE.
So I can set that differently
and set the load balancer
differently for each one,
and it'll work just fine.
Let's go back to the deck.
Yeah!
Now, that's all very exciting.
And that's actually
all I'm going
to share with you this morning.
What you probably were
interested in, too, is like,
what are people actually
doing with this stuff?
That's me showing a
demo app that we built
and everyone can do and download
on their own, fun stuff.
However, right now, I'd
like to introduce you
to Tobias Palmborg, who
is the CTO of NetEnt,
who is one of our early
customers of GKE On-Prem.
And he's going to tell
you more about what
their team did with it.
Thanks, man.
TOBIAS PALMBORG:
Thank you, Matt.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAVIS: [INAUDIBLE].
TOBIAS PALMBORG: And thanks
for an awesome presentation.
I mean, I can do those
demos, so very nice work.
Thanks for having me here.
I'm super keen on being here.
And it's been super interesting
to get an early view on GKE
On-Prem [? with ?] [? Matt. ?]
So I'm going to try and walk
you through a little bit about
how we're thinking about it
and what we're doing with it.
But first of all,
Tobias, my name.
I'm CTO of NetEnt.
And NetEnt, for those
of you who don't know,
we're a B2B company within the
online casino gaming industry.
We produce games.
I have a slot machine
brand on me today.
We have a number of
titles that we've done.
We produce about-- well, we have
right now about 200 games live.
So we produce those games.
And we produce a
platform that runs
those games for our customers.
And our customers, they are
operators in the online casino
industry.
The important part here-- and
it's really what Matt showed
before in the early slides--
the reason why we're
looking into this,
and it's the
jurisdictional reason.
That's our main one.
NetEnt has about 28
licenses across our markets.
And the gambling
industries is sort
of going through a pretty fast
reregulation, I would say.
Regulators, however, are not the
most modern people right now.
So going cloud is not something
that we can do in all places,
until last year pretty
much, because then we
saw a pretty big shift in
some of the regulators.
So cloud is more
and more OK to use.
The problem for us then
was that it was only some.
So if we were to
cloud at that point,
we would end up in
that position where
you have on-prem that looks in
one way and then going cloud
looks a completely
different way.
And with regard
to our complexity,
I'm going to go through that
a little bit more later on.
We kind of said that we
don't want to take that path.
We're not ready for that.
We can't add yet another
layer of complexity.
So we decided to
stay on-prem until we
got to know about
GKE On-Prem and got
some early access to it.
And it looks really promising.
And what Matt has
shown is really
what's going to help us to have
that sort of single control
plane and still be able to
use both on-prem and GKE.
Just some numbers around
what I call our complexity,
so I said 200 customers.
We build what we
call a CasinoModule
for each and every customer.
So each customer has at
least one CasinoModule.
So we have 500 CasinoModules,
translating into something
around 3,500 VMs.
So it's quite a lot
to keep track of.
We have 10 data centers
around the world
to support this and support
the licenses we have.
And as I said, 200
games, adding new games,
adding new customers, it's kind
of like the complexity is just
increasing a lot.
So adding that hybrid without
having really control over it
would be really hard for us.
These are current data centers.
And we're growing.
We are setting one up
right now in Pennsylvania
for the opening of that market.
The beauty of how we see
GKE On-Prem falling out
is that we can set up our data
centers in a different way
than we've done before.
So we've been working
with container platforms
and in Kubernetes for
the last two years.
And we run OpenShift clusters
in all our 10 data center.
And it's not a
trivial thing to do.
It's quite a lot of
maintenance to do this.
And we were looking
for a managed
service for quite some time.
And now we got it, right?
So this is pretty much
the sort of migration path
we're looking at.
You see almost the same
names that you saw before
in the data centers.
The blue boxes are the ones
where we're going cloud.
We have Finland as one example.
It's a regulated
market and so happens
to be that Google has a
data center in Finland.
So we're starting there.
It's up and running.
We're looking to
move our admin sites.
And then we're looking to
build small effective data
centers for where the
regulators require [? cell ?]
and run GKE On-Prem on them.
I don't have a fancy
demo as Matt has,
but I have a really good video
clip from a couple of weeks
back when some of the
developers with us
managed to get the first game
rounds played in GKE On-Prem.
And that was really
early, so it was alpha.
So I want to show you that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This shows a workload
on GKE On-Prem Alpha.
We start with showing that
this is an ingress object.
That is actually in
the GKE On-Prem Alpha.
So we now make a
kubectl CLI command.
And we see that we
now have an [? SVP, ?]
which is our gaming platform.
And it's deployed
in NetEnt on-prem.
Good.
So let's go to the web browser.
And let's visit
the CasinoModule.
You can see it works.
And now, let's go to the admin
page of the CasinoModule.
Let's log in.
Here, we have an internal
test page for our games.
We will log in with Swedish
player and no password,
and log in.
And let's start Starburst,
our most popular game.
Now, we are starting.
And now we're playing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BURSTING]
So now we're playing On-Prem.
[PLONKING]
[BURSTING]
Woo-hoo!
OK, so that's the demo.
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
TOBIAS PALMBORG: So you can
almost feel the excitement
there, right?
[APPLAUSE]
And it might look like just
a simple game for you guys.
But this is surely a
game changer for us.
This is going to mean a
lot good things for us
when we expand into
new markets and try
to modernize our platform
as we started to do.
So I think that's all for me.
Again, I'm really
looking forward
to the rest of what you
guys will bring with Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]